fcking Xfinity man
Xfinity order
food
tired
hello I really it really sucks that it
keeps chunking my streams up as well
because
um just of stupid Xfinity
like [ __ ]
that's okay let me order some food on
the side here I couldn't the internet
was down um and then we'll do a little
bit more work on this and then we'll
call it let me think today
covered and
just make sure that went
through hello twitch folks again we got
shut off a second ago because of uh
Xfinity thank you very
much but I think we're in a pretty good
spot now like I just fixed up the code
for this let me pull this over I just
fixed up this code so we no longer have
to manually check all the numbers and
now I can do like
this and then we can even do the dire
side
so we can even like test like this I can
play this tank here and uh I forget what
his buttons do I think I have hold on do
I have like a yeah I have this right
here right this is like an AOE this is a
stupidly overpowered clear it randomly
will respawn you uh once in a while as
well that's a that's a feature not a bug
that's for the RL to make it learn
better um I think we'll be able to get
rid of that event
actually but it has like really op clear
like look at
this I think that this life steals a
little bit as
well so like already level three just
off of that so this guy can
jungle the tanks also kind of Jungle
which is
weird how does this do if I go into this
is my own Tower right so I should be
able to
like hold this
button does this hit the tower this does
hit the tower
right and then don't I have a self
heel I thought I had a self heal doesn't
seem to be going
off 20 XP yeah lots of XP
I thought I had a self heal but some of
the skills don't seem to be going off
correctly we'll have to do some
testing anything else core that I've
forgotten in this
port could technically try to build this
for web already right
I think we'll probably do that tomorrow
I'm a bit tired to do that
tonight but uh tomorrow we'll be able to
play around with this on the
web maybe we'll make a little site or
something I don't
know I'm trying to think what else we
should do was there a mini map no
there's no mini
map that's a separate render mode
technically so technically I could put
the mini map like on the same page or
whatever but currently it's it's a
separate render
mode and if I wanted to do a mini map
properly I'd have to do it a little bit
differently than I'm doing it now
because it's pretty
written I think we should just go
through and see if all the skills
actually work that would probably be the
most useful thing right now right
there play the
support has a hook a heal and a stun
this does not seem to be uh doing
anything
right yeah that just wastes Mana it
doesn't actually do anything the AOE
heal does heal me and then 75 Mana to
stun I believe this
works yeah
stunned so for some reason the the uh
the hook does not work
so let's mark this
one
fixed what's
next burst nuke assassin
okay is this supposed to be the burst
character I think this is the Assassin
isn't
it yeah this is the
Assassin so are these out of
order let's put these let's put these in
order
cuz it's supposed to be
support then burst I mean support then
okay so we know assassin works right
it's you have
um yeah you have your TP damage your AOE
we've already checked these this one
works so let's check the birth character
which is birth Barracuda here so you
have a a nuke an AOE and a stun and your
full combo is very expensive
right so you have this nuke which should
be able to like
oh yeah look at that yeah yeah you just
wreck a fool you you do a lot of
damage and then you also have a stun
which is an AOE stun which is
ridiculously overpowered yeah look at
that that's lud Chris that's rid that's
just disgusting
honestly okay so that's the birth
character and now we have the tank
here the tank has
an AOE dot which is this thing right
which is freaking broken which is
awesome uh and then it has a self heel
the self heel does not appear to go
off and then there is an engage AOE or
whatever oh yeah the engage
AOE so the engage it engages but it
doesn't seem to
push so let's just kill these real quick
NSA doesn't seem to heal us very
much so this one engages but
doesn't push but I think the push skills
are broken do fix this one doesn't go
off for some
clam so it has a carry should have a
retreat slow or whatever so I should be
able to go up to this guy and just like
wreck a full
right yeah this does not actually do
anything the slow damage does do
something and then we have this basic
AOE does this actually INF inflict a
slow I didn't see
definitely does
damage there a [ __ ] ton of
Mana yeah it does inflict a slow you can
see
it doesn't seem to be slowed very much
though it has the status
broken oh okay so it's literally just
hard disabled right there
Mana
cost
heal target.
TM it should be not
let's fix
this we go out as
tank this is like a funny
engage and then you know we can fight
stuff like this
right we can just drain things and then
we can full
heal we can drain things yeah this thing
is like a perfect jungler to be honest
and then it actually has disengage as
well is like really nice it has Mana
problems for sure which I think balances
a little we got to fix the flicker like
when something
dies like yeah I definitely have Mana
problems
but not a huge
deal okay so this now
right uh okay so it worked backwards I
think which is not what you want it
instead of hooking it it pulled me to it
so hook
here pull Target
player so
push player
Target wait pull I think I have it
backwards somehow
right it should be
player Target minus amount right
let's see if this gives us the hook
Behavior we're looking
for yeah look at that we hooked it you
saw
that we hooked
him and now we stun
him now this is a little bit limited by
the fact that we only have like a five
tile Vision range so you can't hook from
very far you can only Hook from like
around here
but it does
work okay and now let's see if we can do
the
engage engage
AOE on the tank the idea with the engage
is that I mean do we want it to be an
engage maybe it should be an engage pull
not an engage push right that's what the
the tank wants to pull stuff to it
doesn't it
I think it's pushing me away from them
or
uh this support is more aggressive
supports don't always have a disengage
right that's if they're weak supports
sometimes they have engages what do you
you know supports can have engages they
can be engaged supports right that's a
do you saw that something weird just
happened there
it it's like pulling me to them or
something instead of me of them to me
slow the carry clam is supposed to have
a retreat
right yeah see this pushes them away
from me not the other way around
yeah it's like pulling them to me or
something
I think they're just like a couple small
tweaks
yeah I'm like pulling myself towards it
or something
food pretty soon well we'll push a
little bit to see if I can fix a couple
last things I'm getting pretty tired but
you never know maybe uh maybe we uh we
make a little progress
oh that worked right did you see
that it
worked ah I got to get away right and
look it
cool I think it's got to be like
substantially better than that we'll see
like this
maybe this is the one skill that never
gets used so we may as well buff it a
bunch
this why does I do I not go farther than
that I should be able to like get
farther than that right with the retreat
AOE slow n this is not an AOE slow this
is this is supposed to be like you jump
back and slow them it's like do you know
uh Caitlyn's net how Caitlyn's net like
jumps back
it's like a jump back and then slow the
though like this should jump me way the
hell back right
yeah like
that that's what I was
expecting but this looks like it jumped
me back five
but I think I'm only getting one of the
activations is what's
happening which means a third of this
skill this is like a really cool ability
if you think about it if like it's
actually strong like cuz I can just go
like
Boop and what did this
am I norming it
wrong I could be norming this wrong
so we go
here we take the
clam these are cool I'm going to do an
animation system with your stuff very
soon okay so what happened
here target 151 DX and
wait it says I pushed
from
49 it says that I put pushed quite far
actually I don't know that I believe it
am I just Mis gauging distances
here
like I am one cell right
right is it 15
tiles maybe it
is I mean that's pretty
far so maybe I was just dramatically
underestimating um the amount that needs
to be pushed
do you get to level
25 an extra 2.5 off of it so I double
this to 0.1 and then I'll take this down
to like three or four
maybe that looks pretty
good so how strong is this
own maybe not but with the stun or the
slow it definitely does right you can do
like a slow damage let's do like a
WQ okay well this slow is not affecting
this perer at all
moving back yeah yeah yeah that's like a
quirk of the uh the manual
oh it's only getting it's only getting
applied to players that's why
definitely some small bugs to fix
here well my food is here so uh we will
fix this
tomorrow I'm going to commit this for
enjoy plus
sketch
oh
what oh you literally like sketched okay
and then you do like
this water rising in a
tank
okay drop shadow on
units level indicator Ator there
okay 4 wait 480 is really low
res you double it
right it's 720p is 720 by
1080 oh yeah yeah yeah the UI has to get
Scaled up though this is way too small
obviously this is like this is pretty
solid and you don't you don't see that
far but this is like this is about how
far the agents would see anyways and
then you can like full screen it if you
want right but this is
good solid work I like the water Motif I
think that might be a little tricky to
do if you want it to fill
continuously we might be able to cheat
something with that
though very
nice this guy is so
funny man make this into like an apng or
something I want to add this as an emote
this guy is really
funny like I'm not going to be replacing
my puffer with him or anything because
he's uh you know he's rather silly but
it's a it's a great meme I like this
well I really like the way you do your
animations
these towers would be the next thing to
slot in if you want to do uh if you want
to like you know finish this up and put
it on the Sprite sheet
um you know just like tip one of these
neon uh like cyan and one of them red or
whatever and we're good to
go
sweet I kind of like how you did the
mini map where it's like this abstract
thing it's so funny
all right I gotta get going I got to get
food but thank you that looks
cool you have a good
one and I will be back tomorrow probably
early afternoon PST see you around and
don't forget be the puffer he eats Stars
where
uh the puffer eats stars and if you
check right
here we're at 955 Stars so close almost
to the big thousand Milestone so if you
want to help us
out star the puffer